[Music]
that's right my tell to four yes from
this is spinal tap in 1984 we then had
to wait till 1992 for break like the
wind and then in 2009 back from the dead
and ever since then we were wondering
what was uh Derek smalls was up to we
wonder no more because I have right here
on the desk the new album smalls change
and meditations upon aging and the man
the myth the legend himself Derek smalls
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
sir I'm great I'm really great a few
great I look great all right I'll great
the whole thing is great the whole thing
is great so what what caused you to want
to get back in the studio and and chop
it up again Derek well you know the band
we we've dissolved so many times we
don't break up you know it's not the you
bastard you brush you son of a [ __ ] a
so you start throwing things cuz we
don't never had that many things to
throw so it just after 2009 you
mentioned mm-hmm we played Glastonbury
Festival in outside London and we played
do Wembley Arena in London so whether
you were out of London or inland and
there we were and I thought right here
we go tap 3.0 or 4.2 and what happened
exactly
that was my question I was sitting by
the phone waiting for it to ring yeah
and it doesn't ring and so I do the
natural thing I call it the telephone
company and they say it's not ice which
they always say but in this case it was
true uh-huh
and I just realized the band had
dissolved again and it were like if you
put a little cube of sugar yes in a
saucer of warm coffee mmm it'll be there
for a while and then you turn around
later this after that's it that's
happened that's job so I looked at the
saucer and that was what I saw and I
thought right
have to do something else so I went to
the Netherlands because it's so close
yeah and got involved in television was
I was a judge on a reality competition
show called rock stars with a said you
thought you call it a Z but it's still
you know it's the Lazaro sure for the
horse yeah yeah and I was good at that I
was
like Oh judge was this very amazing
chick singer how can I say that sure go
for it is there is sports here I'd say
yeah I guess a chick singer sure who was
lead singer in a neo punk band called
hot garage and we were getting it on we
you know we were beating the hell out of
Dutch Idol and then all of a sudden they
come in one day say we're going a
different way we're gonna be tomorrow's
hip-hop heroes with a Zed so I it was it
was a case I figured it out later it's a
case of either they kept me or they kept
this ed and unfortunately yeah you got
thrown overboard for so always I was I
moved I have a friend Eddie dregs who
lives in Albania and he has a a neo near
death metal band a near death metal
called chainsaw vermin and I was hanging
out with him and thinking this can't be
all there is to it this can't be the way
it ends for Derek and all of a sudden I
saw this advert for the British fund for
aging rockers which they you know they'd
had all this austerity in Great Britain
said there's all this money left over
yes and they were giving grants to aging
rock who else have they given grants to
do I think I was the first so you were
if you don't mind me mixing metaphors
the George Washington of that situation
I was the Charles the first of it okay I
understand yeah okay we don't like to
talk about George was final tappers is
the one who's do you think is the one I
mean a mix it up here I don't mean to
create any issues between you and maybe
you're a long time
colleagues but nobody the one that's
preventing maybe a reunion here Derek
that's a good question so good that
don't really know the answer to it Nigel
I know it's got his hands full he's been
breeding miniature livestock for a few
years down and didn't and so he's he's
got his thing you know guitar players
are excessive people by nature you would
that's what you were doing yeah when I
was doing my still with them and you're
still pent that you're being excessive
that's how you said I'm a guitar player
not by actually played
but by being excessive right sure right
so that's not you know he's pushing it
he's always pushing the envelope right
and sometimes just throwing the envelope
away and sending the thing without an
envelope so he's got these little
miniature goats now they're very cute
but they're too small to milk a it's
just pushing it you know David I have no
idea I have no idea where years well I
mean I get these I don't you see it I
don't use the internet because I was
addicted that's right I heard that that
you went to you went therapy the therapy
for addiction to the Internet it was a
place out in the countryside called
crosswinds and it was - two bouts of it
uh-huh and so I don't use the internet
but David sent me these letters in the
post sometimes right I'm thinking great
let's see what David's got to say right
sure and I open them up and it's always
the same thing
it's Chinese pictograms bloody Chinese
bloody pictograms which I don't read and
I'm not ashamed of that sure but so I
don't know if he's saying ah let's get
back together
or great new record mate or send me the
duck and some dim sum you know no no
bloody idea Derek smalls of spinal tap
here on the Rich Eisen show is it true
that spinal tap was once upon a time
under consideration to play a Super Bowl
so under consideration is what we
thought that's what they told us we went
in and and played our set mm and we got
a couple notes back to loud was one of
them yeah do you have to bleep that okay
all right but that's what they said yeah
they talk like footballers you know
that's the way footballers talk and then
the second thing was their lawyer rang
up yes and they said we're gonna have to
be held harmless of waiver dough immune
immunized in United or something like
that right against if anything happens
to the drummer and and we said well we
can't do that we can't make make you
know the NFL hole or whatever it is you
know
it's like what would that cost you know
in a bloody Super Bowl oh they're gonna
come at us and say oh you ruined our
Super Bowl with your dead drummer you
always four billion pounds or whatever
you know it made no sense and and they
moved on do we know who they was that
was openly a year they went with Michael
Jackson yeah yeah and he didn't have a
drummer so I guess that didn't have the
problem yeah I would have been amazing
it would have been amazing and it would
have been bloody loud too
so you're wearing your it looks like you
got some kit on here I have the
Shrewsbury shrews Jersey uh-huh which is
I don't know if you follow the shrews I
don't follow the shrews what what league
is the shrews and they're in league one
in a British football which contrary to
what you might think it's not the top
the Premier League is the top sure yes
and League one is three levels down from
the sea are you saying the shrews have
been relegated multiple times over I
think they've been re relegated but
they've here's the thing about the
shrews yes because you're laughing some
ruse have the record still standing yes
for the most times a British team has
beaten an English team has beaten the
Welsh team as well shame is that right
yeah six no kidding yeah almighty shrews
I didn't mean I didn't mean to scoff I
didn't mean to scoff hail shrews so I I
got into the shrews yeah so to speak yes
about 62 you know Elton Sean had just
bought a football team yeah I call it
football you call it soccer yeah and I
thought well that's what a rocket does
right yes so I saw the original shrews
Jersey and I thought I like to look at
that Jersey mm-hmm I'll buy that team
and now look at you well I didn't buy
the team but I got they give me the
Jersey so that's it so at least you got
that going forgot that goes who else
before I let you go Derek yes this is on
this album with Steve how long do you
have
go for Steve feisty Joe Satriani Steve
Lukather Richard Thompson
Dweezil Zappa
all our guitars hmm Taylor Hawkins Chad
Smith Jim Keltner Gregg Bissonette some
of the drummers Rick Wakeman Paul
Shaffer keyboard players David Crosby
David bloody Crosby Donald bloody Fagan
vocalizing with this wow it's pretty
much all-star fantastic yeah available
where our music is so it's extremely
available
smalls change Derek smalls it's been an
honor to have you here thank you rich
it's been great to be with you thank you
very much the man who first lepton to
the scene with the all-white Jamaican
band ska face before joining lambs blood
the Christian heavy-metal man yeah and
then whole lotta Lord was all hit was
that what a lotta Lord and then tap yeah
good to see you sir great to see you
Derek smalls here on the Rich Eisen show
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience